Esta es una pequeña población campesina
de las miles que hay repartidas por toda
Ucrania es tan especial está en el norte
de la ciudad de kiefa una hora y media y
muy cerca también a la frontera con
viola a Rusia de hecho esto fue una de
las primeras poblaciones que cayó en
control de las fuerzas rusas durante la
invasión el 24 de febrero ellos
estuvieron aquí hasta que se retiraron
de esta parte del norte de Ucrania y
ellos nos cuentan que aquí ya vivieron
en ese momento un invierno o un final de
invierno este año bastante duro porque
cuando estaban los rusos aquí cortaron
la electricidad y ahora vuelven a vivir
algo parecido no tienen luz en sus casas
va y viene pero prácticamente no la
tienen pero logran calentarse con unas
calefacciones de madera a lo que ellos
están acostumbrados y dicen que viene
mal Ellos están acostumbrados a pasar
inviernos bastante duro y que tienen las
la manera para para hacerlo y por esta
razón en algunas comunidades de hecho
también al gobierno ucraniano ha
invitado a residentes de áreas urbanas a
moverse a poblaciones como estas para
quitarle presión a la capacidad
eléctrica de las grandes ciudades en esa
crisis que tienen energética y que están
esperando nuevos ataques también de las
fuerzas rusas lo que hará que ese sea
tal vez el peor invierno para los
ucranianos especialmente en las ciudades
que no están acostumbradas